[Musique]
l'autre n'est pas notre et l'autre est
quelqu'un qui a la même capacité
commandes de réfléchir le problème qui
se pose c'est accepter que des gens très
différents
bien sûr qu'il est temps de changer et
de l'autre côté il ya ceux qui peut
changer mais les fronts les promesses
mirobolantes ne s'aperçoit de plus on ne
les écoute pas
il est fort et intelligent et des
fidèles restés comme ici et là des
secours près quand il faut dire non à
dire non c'est quelque chose de toujours
s'intéresser aux gens qui ne voudrais
vous dire les trois directions qui me
paraissent et les trois directions bond
en même temps ce que chacun d'entre nous
citoyens français nous ayons un vrai
qu'on trouve et il ne prépare première
direction qu'il y ait des engagements
un petit nom mais majeurs avec des dates
de réalisation des vérités sur pc
deuxièmement que pour tout ce qui
concerne notre vie de tous les jours le
pouvoir reproche qu'on puisse saisir et
de terminer dans les chaumes bas et
qu'ils doivent rendre des comptes
troisième
reste à la médiatisation il faut une
vraie europe qui puisse tout est
possible pour défendre nos intérêts et
aussi pour tout ce qui touche au dépôt
je pense clairement non pas seulement
par des idées mais par des valeurs je
pense à la médiation on ne repart pas
je pense que françois ne vont pas porter
caution de la cité certaines fois et je
pense que c'est quelqu'un aussi qu'il ya
beaucoup de moyens c'est quelquefois la
lutte contre l'illettrisme a été de ses
premiers combats
il a fait très que partie 2
de tous les comités de soutien il s'est
engagé auprès de tous ceux qui luttent
et quand helmut fritz et il a fait en
sorte en étant donné sa chance à tours
ce qu'ils respectent et pouvoir proche
on peut avoir et ça commence
[Musique]